salut la team mantallot il ya quelques
semaines environ j'ai essayé de battre
akinator et aujourd'hui c'est vous qui
allez le combattre juste avant de
commencer je voulais préciser que pour
ma venue en suisse je vais faire un meet
up avec chico nono je vous en dit plus à
la fin de la vidéo
parce que pour l'instant génériques ça
fait un petit moment que j'avais envie
de refaire une vidéo avec akinator nom
va pas faire comme la dernière fois
quand j'étais avec romain pour ceux qui
ont pas vu la vidéo je vous la met ici
alors comment ça va se passer
aujourd'hui je vais vous le dire comment
ça va se passer
j'ai choisi deux personnes est un objet
à l'avance je vais essayer de les faire
deviner akinator mais vous en temps réel
avec les questions que je pose akinator
vous devez essayer de les trouver
également c'est donc le battle team
menthe à l'eau akinator pour utiliser
votre esprit de synthèse votre
concentration votre logique et je suis
sûr que vous allez trouver au moins un
ou deux voire les trois personnages est
il de sexe féminin non ton personnage at
il en france
oui même si on sait pas réellement où ce
personnage avis en tout cas une légende
urbaine là-dessus ton personnage at il
vendu des dix noms ton personnage est il
un youtube heures oui bah dis donc il va
vite ton personnage at il fait des
vidéos avec cyprien non je ne pense pas
ton personnage fait il partie du milieu
du jeu vidéo alors pas vraiment pas
exactement jeu maintenant au personnage
at il plus de 18 ans oui ton passage at
il un rapport avec le milieu du sport et
là je vais cliquer sur le nom c'est pas
du tout tibhrine shape le personnage
porte-t-il devinette non ton personnage
et il est en couple avec une femme je
sais pas ton personnage se produit-il
sur scène non on est déjà à 11 12
questions si vous avez déjà trouvé vous
vous pouvez le mettre dans les
commentaires mon personnage est il de
couleur de peau métisse non ton
personnage fait-il de vidéos comiques
non même si me fait rire mais non sans
passager d'une moto non ton personnage
at il un rapport avec le monde culinaire
non plus rapport avec les
extraterrestres non tu n'es tu pas
sylvain du rif donc parachute il déteste
high tech
oui il ya une question qui a sauté j'ai
vu j'ai vu un truc passé c'est oui ce
truc était bon passage fait-il de vidéos
déballage produits louis oui ces terres
romanes de technos mts c'était pour voir
si vous aviez regardé la vidéo
précédente sur la chine a tort parce que
c'était avec romain que vous l'avez fait
j'ai pas vu je crois qu'on était à
15-16 question peut-être vous aviez
trouvé deuxième test possibilités encore
une fois de marquer un point pour vous
déjà 1,1 point pour akinator s'il a
trouvé avant vous en tout cas avec un
nouveau personnage ton personnage est il
dans le domaine de la musique
non estimé youtuber non est-il masculin
oui ton personnage depuis plus de 30 ans
non je vous le dis tout de suite pour
connaître ou avoir un peu regardé les
vidéos quand même ton personnage at il
déjà vu ton visage au oui si ton
personnage je le souhaitais accepterait
une relation amoureuse avec lui non
j'aime ce personnage mais non at il lui
même parent que ton personnage non ton
personnage partie des vêtements non mon
personnage est tout le temps nu ton
personnage at il une histoire qui a mal
tourné avec la fouine
non sauf s'il ya eu une embrouille que
je ne connais pas elle fait au passage
est un chien non est ce que ton
personnage est un chat oui mon
personnage et achats vous est ce qu'il
vit avec moi oui lui avec moi oui alors
c'est pas du tout la bonne photo mais
oui c'était mon chat c'est à malo vous
l'avez déjà vu dans des vidéos
précédentes à malo si vous avez juste
trouvé que je parlais de mon chat on
peut dire que vous avez battu akinator
si vous avez trouvé que je parlais de
tam malo précisément alors là vous avez
un point bonus troisième partie c'est
sur un objet jamais fait avec les objets
on joue avec les objets et il me pose
comme question est ce un objet alors en
plus c'est pas si évident que ça c'est
un objet je dis oui moi je n'ai même
plus tôt est ce que c'est un rapport
avec le sexe direct en fait eu alors
potentiellement tout peut avoir rapport
mais je ne pense pas non parce que ça
passe plus de 10 kilos non est-ce que ça
c'est à se divertir non est-ce qu'on ne
porte sur soi non est-ce que ça se
trouve dans une cuisine à être plus tôt
est-ce que ça se met dans la bouche
oui a du coup je comprends mieux la
première et la deuxième question est ce
que le contenu est liquide
oui est-ce que de l'alcool non non pas
vraiment est-ce que ça mais avec le sens
de la vie et bien oui pour moi oui mais
je vais maintenant quand même est ce que
ces gars the north que ça ce match non
est ce qu'un bouchon non est ce une
boisson
oui là je sens que dans les commentaires
ça fait j'ai trop mais ou pas est-ce que
c'est chaud non est ce que ces coupes
ans mais qu'est-ce qui se boit qui peut
être coupon est ce que vous avez un
exemple concret d'un truc
pratique de coupe comme ça la langue
qu'il ya plusieurs couleurs non un acte
une baisse naturelle oui plutôt est ce
que ça contient du poisson non parce que
ça se pratique en famille
est ce qu'un objet peut se pratiquer en
famille jeu j'en sais rien ça peut être
utile dans l'eau bah oui ça permet de
faire du jus non un thé glacé
eh bien pas du tout donc on continue moi
je pense que vous êtes nombreux à avoir
déjà trouvé
on continue oui
on est on est parti sur une tarte au
citron ou je suis vraiment un looser
dans mes réponses parce qu'ils me
proposent la même pas pas du tout je
pense est évidemment à une menthe à
l'eau on a posé une colle grec n'a tort
mais comme vous étiez en bateau avec lui
si vous avez trouvé alors vous avez
gagné au moins une manche sur un quine à
tort dites moi dans les commentaires ce
que vous aimeriez que je fasse d'autre
avec akinator ça me fait vraiment marrer
de faire des vidéos avec donc ce serait
sympa d'en faire une troisième un jour
pas forcément tout de suite mais un jour
mettez moi vos idées dans l'école comme
je vous le disais le 21 et 22 octobre
prochain je vais être en spectacle à
lausanne à ouchy un petit peu au sud de
lausanne ots cepeo à l'occasion avec un
youtuber que vous avez déjà vu sur ma
chaîne on organise un mythe hop un petit
peu en collaboration tous les deux
ensemble c'est noam alias chico nono tu
me fait toujours rire quand je dis son
nom via six places en tout à gagner pour
le spectacle est un mythe up avec lui il
ya un espèce de milton great avec lui et
moi à la fin de mon spectacle je vous
laisse aller voir sur sa chaîne en
cliquant sur ce lien ici pour voir tous
les détails de sa dans sa dernière vidéo
et j'en profite pour voir et qu'il ya
toutes les dates de spectacles de ma
tournée qui sont sur mon site internet
où vous avez le lien dans la description
toute la province et paris fin décembre
et une grosse soirée spéciale à
versailles le 31 décembre et gamme voilà
pour aujourd'hui le mental au demain ce
sera enfin la vidéo du my maps vous en
avez envoyé foison moult ils sont
vraiment excellents prenez le temps d'un
petit clic pour vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas déjà fait des fois vous
regardez les vidéos souvent ils vous
n'avez pas percuter vous n'étiez pas
encore abonné et un petit clic sa rapide
et rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
gala